okay good afternoon thanks for inviting
me for the opportunity to give the talk
I did send the abstract item talk mainly
about counting rearrangement of
illusions but I thought I'd split the
talk into two parts so for the first
part i'm going to talk about the the
space of rearrangements that we get so
we've seen some talks of trying to get
from one copy number confirmation to
another for example but we also seen
some discussion on population dynamics
and so i'm going to explore a little bit
the idea that physics has been looking
ensembles of particles for a long time
and developed various methods so i'm
going to explore whether there's things
in there that we can use for in samples
of particles in biology and by on
summers the particles I mean cells and
see whether that's a good idea and so
evony gave a talk that told us how to
explore the space of break confusion
bridges in particularly the inference
and deciding whether some structure
groups occurs from breaking fusion
britches so there's there's an example
of an amplicon we've got some fallbacks
that are going on here so these are all
signs of what we get when we have a
break confusion bridge process we've got
copy number increases and then we've got
this kind of folded structure of going
on so the DNA is wrapping all over the
place and this is kind of a signature of
what we get from a break confusion
bridge process and so just a quick recap
on on what goes on with a broken fusion
bridge so without getting into biology
we can think of it as a break as
occurring at some point we get to
plication up to that break so we get a
kind of symmetric situation going on
here so we've got two symmetric things
and in some sense those two things get
glued together and that process
continues and we end up with these these
folding structures
so the question I'm going to consider
and I'm not just considering it for
break confusion bridge processes and
thinking of there's different mechanisms
that can happen there's broken fusion
bridge there's tandragee plication
processes we've heard about those
inversions as well so there's different
things that can affect the way that
these amplicons are structured and so
when we're kind of trying to get from
one genome to another it's of interest
to kind of say how big is this space
that we're exploring and that's kind of
what I'm going to talk about for the
first half so giving k events so they
could be K very confusion bridges there
could be a mixture of events going on we
can ask how many evolutions are possible
so that's kind of what we mean by saying
how big is this space and so what we're
counting is these evolutions so what I
mean by an evolution as a sequence of
genomic configurations so we're starting
from a wild type and then we every time
we've got one rearrangement we've got a
new structure and the what i mean by an
evolution is that entire set the entire
sequence i should say of genomic
configurations so can ask you how many
so for great confusion bridges i'm just
going to talk you through how this space
kind of grows so there's just we can
think of that line as a reference and
this is one breakage fusion bridge so
you get one folder goes on so if you've
got one break infusion bridges not a
very big space you've got one thing that
happens but if we have it or if we allow
a second foal we can break at the top or
at the bottom and that gives us two
possible structures that can arise so if
we allow to breakage fusion bridges the
spaces of size two so then we can say
what happens if we have a third event so
again we can break it in two places and
that gives us two possible structures
the alternative is that we try and do
more breakage fusion bridges on that
structure so if we do that we can either
have a third break in one of these two
positions so this gives us two more
structures
or we can have a break in this position
here which gives us full possibilities
that goes on so we get four structures
that come out so you can kind of build
up a picture of what this space is like
as we keep doing these break infusion
bridge operations and when we do it we
get this kind of so here's account of
the break infusion bridges we've got and
here is a count of the number of
evolutions that is possible so it's
going to growing in this slightly
unusual power of two so we can write
down a formula for that and get some
idea of the size of the space so that's
if we restrict ourselves just to break
infusion bridges
we can think about doing similar things
with Tanner duplications so again I'm
going to align everything up to a
reference here so this is the reference
the wild-type if we like and so we start
with the normal genome and then if we
got a ton of duplication we've got some
bits of DNA that we want to copy so the
green bit we're going to copy we've got
a green beer DNA there and then we're
copying the piece of DNA and shoving it
next to itself so the ABC becomes a BBC
if you like algebraically but we're
lining these up to the reference so
these two bits are both lined up to the
same place and we've got a connection
from one end to the other so this
representation is a kind of visual
representation of what's going on with a
ton of duplication so we can keep going
so for example the red bit there could
be the next bit that we duplicate so
we've got one copy of the red bit then
another copy of the red bit so this
would be the next structure we'd have if
we allow to download applications to
take place and we can keep going we can
copy the blue and the purple and you can
build up pictures of what and the
sequences of tandem duplications look
like if we allow them to continue so we
can ask similar questions and if we have
tunnel duplications going on so how many
structures can we get and I'll not tell
through this in too much detail but but
these are all the configurations we get
if we allow ourselves to tangier
occasions to occur so we get 11
structures in total so when we kind of
explore this if we allow ourselves one
ton of duplication we get one
configuration if we have to then we've
got 11 configurations which are all
these things here and we can build up
this rapidly growing sequence which is a
very big space and there is a formula
for this so it's a product is that it
it's similar to the very confusion
bridges in that we've got this power of
two in some sense that dominates so what
we'd like to be able to do is to mix
these things up and not just restrict
ourselves to break infusion bridges we
want to allow lots of different
mechanisms to take place and then ask
how big is
the space of rearrangements that we can
have
so how can we go about this well here's
a reference so let's allow ourselves one
tandem duplication to take place so
we've copied this bit in the middle so
that bears to poke a two twice and that
gives us one structure and so we allow
ourselves the second one and this is a
very good fusion bridge event so that
gives us a palindromic bit of DNA so if
we imagine we break it here so that's
the original structure and then copy it
backwards this is what we get if we have
a break confusion bridge following a
tandem duplication so if we do that
we've now got three break points that
have arisen so when we first exploring
this space it's quite natural to try and
add more and more operations below and
then try and come up with some way of
working at how big the spaces but it
doesn't work terribly well what you
actually have to do is kind of go
backwards in time rather than forwards
in time so I we got this reference here
and we kind of assumed that the
reference is this God standard that's
not been touched what we can actually
think is well let's suppose that this
reference is actually a product of a
preceding operation so there is a break
confusion bridge for example to happen
before and this reference is actually
the product of a broken fusion bridge
so when we do that that's no longer the
reference we go back in time and there's
actually an earlier reference that's the
true reference in some sense and we've
now got this sequence of three break
points that kind of run along the
structure in that order so although this
is now folded we do have 1a and 1b and
two so that order is kind of conserved
so then what we can do we've kind of got
a bit of flexibility when we're
exploring this base as long as the order
is conserved we're okay so we can move
these things around and see what
different configurations we get so
that's a representation of those three
break points they've been put on that
structure and actually when we think
about all the different positions that
we could place those three break points
we get two to the power of three
different structures so there's eight
structures there I say two to the power
of three because the three is actually
the number of break points that occurred
afterwards we are to from the tunnel
duplication one from the break confusion
bridge and for each of these choices
we're going to get different copy number
configurations so the space is going to
be different so by kind of going
backwards in time and resetting the
reference we can actually say how many
different configurations we're going to
get
so we just saw that choice that was the
break confusion bridge so we have 2 to
the K choices in general where k is the
number of break points so that's the
number of choices where we did that one
there's an OG vacations I'm not talked
about where this form comes from but you
can do quite a similar argument as to
this one to see where this factor comes
from and so this gives us four possible
choices so for this formula we're
substituting in one because there's one
break point that comes afterwards and
then finally we've got the last one and
this has no follow-on events so we only
actually have one choice there so we can
kind of put all this together and we
just multiply those choices together and
it gives us the total possibilities for
the space so so we restricted in the
sense I'm now saying let's have a break
confusion bridge then a tandem
duplication then a break confusion
bridge and I'm asking how many different
structures can you get if you do them in
that order and then the answer is that
it's 32 different possible
configurations arise so we can do that
in general for a quite a broad sequence
of different types of rearrangements we
fix the things that we want and we just
multiply them together based on this
abduction that's kind of going backwards
in time rather than forwards in time
it's resetting the reference you string
yes I could do it in general so i give
you the terms for those two but we can
do it four inversions we can do it for
inverted duplications and by redefining
the reference we can say our bigger
space is I'm a one issue that's come up
a little bit is that I assume you need
break point use in all this so I'm using
that every time we have a new
rearrangement it's hitting the genome in
new places so I mean that's open to
debate whether you'd want to assume that
but if you do assume that then you can
do this counting mechanism to say how
big this place is and as a rough guide
for the when you put these operations
together the size of the space is
roughly like 2 to the power of n squared
so the size of these spaces of genomic
configurations is growing faster than
exponential it's a big space to explore
so that kind of means that when you get
to when you're looking at lots and lots
of rearrangements and you're trying to
explore this space is going to become
quite difficult quite rapidly
because just a quick question obviously
this is the number of unique outcomes
with a with distinct order of events you
can get the same sequence with a
different set of events different order
of events I almost say you can't have
the nice i'm starting event in the sign
last event touch if you've got genomic
configurations that are different in the
middle and you end up with the same
structure then according to this
definition the evolutions are different
even though the structure you guys a
sailor entry number of unique it will
show you tax yes exactly yeah okay so so
that was a bit about rearrangement so it
was a nice little puzzle that we can
solve the second half is somewhat more
speculative I must admit so the the
system I got in mind is the following so
we can think of this as almost as a
pre-cancer system rather than a cancer
system so the thing about physics is
quite often these systems are quite
nicely controlled and biology is a bit
more chaotic especially cancer systems
but one of the nicest control systems is
actually skin tissue because you've got
this single layer of tissue and there's
only two cells that actually exist in
this layer you've got the proliferating
cells they can divide and produce other
proliferating cells or they can produce
differentiated cells which rise up and
form the top layer of your skin so in
terms of the dynamics the only thing we
really need to worry about is this basal
layer as it's called and there's there's
quite nice precise experiments that
voyages can do we can watch cells we can
see how they divide this is an example
here of a staining experiment where one
cell was stained and then this single a
was observed and the staining spreads
out so you can kind of see how this
clone in a sense is spreading out I mean
just a point to note if you Staind say a
hundred cells in this tissue and what
you tend to find is that most of
those stains actually disappear and you
end up with one very big cloned that
kind of dominates the whole area so that
does have implications in terms of
mutation accumulation because if you
although this is a clone we can think of
these hundred things as a mutation that
arises and so for a skin system what we
would find is that most of the mutations
that arise in this earth in the skin two
ish itself or just drift out of the
system it's a very very small subset of
cells that will actually end up
dominating the layer so just by drift
we're going to find that mutations
accumulate and kind of sweep over the
tissue and there's no selection that
would go on there
and say it so the idea of this and I'm
not going to get get this far is that we
have cells we've got nice information
about cells in terms of how long it
takes a cell to divide what the mutation
rates are for an individual cell I mean
that's actually quite hard to get I
think and then selection we can think of
as acting on the cell in terms of
whether the speed of division speeds are
for example and then in terms of the
population we're interested in things
like the size of the clones that were
getting the tree structures that we've
heard people talking about and we've
seen from syrup some of these mutation
sweeps that occur so these are kind of
macroscopic things and these are
microscopic things so in terms of
population dynamics it would be nice to
be able to join these two two things
together so that's the Holy Grail so in
terms of population dynamics the
temptation is to use Markovian dynamics
they're very popular and I think that
popular cause they're convenient because
the math is quite nice so in terms of
cells I'm just drawing attention to some
limitations if you assume Markovian
dynamics you assume that the cell cycle
is actually exponentially distributed
now this is data from cells so cells
have been washed and they've been time
to see how long they take to divine and
you do that for lots of cells and you
build up a picture and this is what
their life cycle looks like so it's
reasonably close to a gamma distribution
and there's nothing like an exponential
distribution see that you can then say
say what does that really matter well I
think it does in terms of the way that
these things grow so this is just a
simple cell population growth if you see
mix exponentially distributed for one
unit of time you get this explosion of e
to the power of tea at the other end of
a Galton Watson type model where you've
got one so then it divides it exactly
one time unit you get two cells then
four then eight etc then the growth is
different between the two and actually
the real data the gamma distribution
sits somewhere between the two so the
growth is going to be a lot slower when
we're dealing with gamma distributions
will be if we assume Markovian dynamics
so it's the lifetime distribution in
terms of modeling the way populations
change is quite important so in terms of
ecological modelling this is often
referred to as age structure so the age
structure is quite important another
aspect that can occur so this is just a
simulation so we take one cell we let it
divide or we let the population have 99
cell divisions so we're going to end up
with a hundred cells and then if we
assume we get of the order of one
mutation per division you can play
around with that parameter we can then
ask how many cells have lots of
mutations and how many cells don't have
many mutations now this is the standard
Markovian model and what we find is we
can find lots of cells that don't have
many mutations and we can find cells
that have plenty of mutations now in
terms of kind of transitioning if you're
trying to accumulate mutations then this
is going to be an easier system to
accumulate but this is the one that's a
bit more realistic so in reality it
probably takes clones longer to pick up
mutations than standard Markovian
dynamics would do
so I'm not going to get into the
specifics too much i'm just going to
draw analogies so in terms of physics
we've may be seen Feynman diagrams
before we got two particles come in and
then two particles come out the
particles change type now this is or it
might be a bit more familiar we've got a
normal cell it changes into a mutant so
it's changing species just like we have
in physics and we get death as well so
the other thing is that we've got
particles changing in number we've got
cells changing in number so there's a
lot of analogy that goes on here and I
mean it was noticed in the 70s and 80s
by these two guys i mean there's a guy
called die boy who worked out how to use
this kind of methods for chemical
reactions and politi in the 80s worked
out how to use this kind of machinery
from physics to actually have a go at
birth death process is so there's a
question of whether we can kind of do
the non-markovian version of what was
going on with politi so I'm just going
to kind of go through the two different
fields if you like so what we can think
of is the caftan in physics we've got Q
is the position of a particle along the
same biology we've got a is the age of a
cell that's the analogy so in physics
we've got States so I'm going to say
that this so we're that's the state of
three particles I'm going to say this is
a state of three cells where those are
the ages of the three cells in physics
we have a superposition which we can
think of as a wave packet this is a
superposition but this is a real
probabilistic interpretation because
this function here represents the
probability of having n cells with a
certain spread of Ages perhaps most
importantly is the following so here
we've got the evolution of states
equation that we go from Heisenberg and
what we can do is we can take the way
that birth death process is evolved and
we can write out an equation that is
very close to what you get in quantum
mechanics so H
is that our all tonian and this thing
here is an operator that describes how
the birth and death goes on so so it's
not just an analogy like we've got at
the top of the board here the fact that
this is true as well means we can really
treat this as a dynamical system and use
the methods of quantum field theory so
I'm not going to the details but for
example is a kind of matrix element this
gives you the probability density
function another thing that population
dynamics are interested in is the
distribution of the size we can also get
that out Feynman diagrams are quite
famous but in a very real sense if you
actually go through the machinery the
Feynman diagram that you get here when
you turn it into the biological problem
this thing here that we think of as a
tree representing a birth-death process
is actually the Feynman diagram for this
system and so what you can do is you can
use all this machinery and you can
actually construct path integral
representations of all these different
systems that goes on so it gives you a
completely different set of machinery
that you can start to think about these
problems so I just forget I mean this
was a curve that I had earlier so there
we had the exponential growth of the
Markovian system this was the galton
watson process where it's stepping up
and the blue is from the real data so
you can kind of use all this machinery
and you can come up with expressions
describing the blue is the growth of the
population there for gamma distributed
systems so you can use this machinery to
start to get information out about how
populations are growing
so having said earlier I mean that the
caveat is the following I mean the the
aim of this which I've not got as far as
doing is to try and analyze skin systems
to describe how clones are growing and
how the mutations are spreading through
something where we've got a system that
is quite nice to control so I've not got
that for all I've actually done is model
a basic system so there's the
possibility that we can use these
physical techniques to actually analyze
some of the systems that are a bit more
well behaved whether these methods from
physics will translate to cancer systems
where the behavior of the cells is a lot
more chaotic I don't know but it would
be interesting to try yes I mean the
other thing to add is that quantum field
theory although it looks at small
particles I mean there's a lot of
quantum field theory that does material
physics so material physics has lots and
lots of particles and similarly with
biology we have lots of logic lots of
lots of particles here so I'm given that
there's been decades of people doing
this stuff though there is the
possibility that there might be methods
though that we could use to try and
bring together information about cells
at the microscopic to say what's going
at the macroscopic level
inicia I just like to thank Tom ciao we
did the work on the aging structures
Luke Renteria was the rearrangements and
then I got data from Peter Campbell and
these guys were responsible for doing
the cell watching time stop their
questions that we start a natural
question about the first part the more
common situation in there in the
literature is where you have a target
validation or genome and suppose you'll
you know how to compute the shortest
path can you tell how many alternative
solution is are you techniques able to
make identities and yeah the short the
short answer to that is is no I think I
mean it's interesting question say the
business of counting the evolutions you
can do because the structure is allowing
you to do that but if you say something
like here is this copy number
configuration how many different paths
are there to get to that configuration I
don't have good answers to that question
and it will be nice they usually
calculate the shortest path well yeah I
don't know actually I mean four
inversions we know we can but and for
break confusion bridges I guess you know
just the FP maybe but if you mix it up
yeah I don't know yeah
do you intersperse deletions into them
into the one of the one of the events
that could happen that actually
constrains a space because if you lose
an allele the mixing and deletions into
that I haven't you you do see that
happen with break confusion bridges for
example so you can't have a sequence of
very confusion bridges where the break
confusion bridge deletes fold from
earlier break confusion bridges so you
see you've got five folds in the system
but you have no idea whether it was five
cycles or whether it is 50 cycles and
they kept you know you're deleting stuff
so I have been ignoring that but you're
right it will constrain the system
because you either get down to one
allele or the DNA is going okay it's a
good